- Ils étaient des milliers
à faire la file. Les plus
courageux sont arrivés à l'aube.
Tous ont attendu le temps
qu'il fallait, parfois pendant
des heures, pour défiler devant
le cercueil de leur idole.
Guy Lafleur a laissé sa marque,
littéralement, dans le coeur
de bien des partisans.
Ils sont venus d'un peu partout,
de tous les horizons, de toutes
les générations, pour lui dire
au revoir une dernière fois.
- C'est une personne que...
qui est très humaine,
qui a toujours été disponible,
puis on voulait être là
pour lui aujourd'hui.
- Guy, c'est une légende
à Thurso, puis... t'sais,
quand tu viens de Thurso,
même si tu l'as pas vu jouer,
bien, Guy Lafleur, ça fait
partie de la communauté.
- Un moment de communion
collective pour la province.
Le Québec pleure l'un
des plus grands héros
sportifs de son histoire.
RON FOURNIER, ancien arbitre
et commentateur sportif
- Avec les Rangers et les
Nordiques, c'était bien agréable
de voir son retour au jeu,
mais... avec le Ca
dans les années 70 où on
remportait des coupes Stanley
par-dessus coupes Stanley,
ça, c'était Guy.
C'était Ti-Guy, t'sais.
- Dans une ambiance solennele s,
Guy Lafleur repose
à côté de sa famille
en chapelle ardente.
Et aussi des trophées qui ont
bâti ssa renommée.
Mais c'est sa personnalité qui
a laissé une trace indélébile.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT
premier ministre du Québec
it pas la langue
de bois. Et puis, j'en parlais
avec son épouse, ça a pas
toujours été facile avec Jacques
Lemaire, avec... le Canadien,
avec... bon. Donc, il s'est mis
des fois un petit peu dans
le trouble. Ça m'arrive moi
aussi, d'ailleurs.
Et... Hein! Et, bien, c'est ça.
"What yohat you get."
VALÉRIE PLANTE
mairesse de Montréal
- Guy Lafleur nous rendait
fiers. C'était un homme qui
était fier, c'était un joueur
de hockey très fier, très
talentueux. Il va avoir
marqué beaucoup de monde
par sa générosité, par
son authenticité, sa passion
et bien sûr son talent.
- Un talent hors norme qui
lui a valu cinq coupes Stanley,
trois championnats des marqu
Un vedeterriat instantané.
Sans jamais pour autant
lui faire oublier
ses compagnons d'armes.
RÉJEAN HOULE, ancien joueur,
Canadiens de Montréal
- Le monde lui envoyait
des cadeaux puis ainsi de suite.
Il prenait les cadeaux, puis
il les donnait à notre personnel
de soutien. Il voulait
s'assurer que notre monde,
que son entourage heureux.
Il prenait bien soin de tout
le monde. Tout le monde
va te dire aujourd'hui:
a tout le temps pris
soin de moi." Donc, nous,
on a été chanceux, les gars
de troisième, quatrième trios.
Il a pris soin
de nous autres aussi.
- Une générosité qui
lui a toujours permis
de se faire pardonner
ses excès en tous genres.
YVON LAMBERT, ancien joueur,
Canadiens de Montréal
- Lui et Gilles Villeneuve...
- Ah oui! C'est vrai!
tunnel Lafontaine
au vieux pont de Québec :
58 minutes.
- Une vie à cent miles à l'heure
au cours de laquelle il n'aura
laissé personne indifférent.
Ici Alexandre Gascon,
Radio-Canada, Mon